[Music]
this is such a cool idea you're playing
a fictionalized version of yourself yeah
in this new show don't trust the being
apartment 23. which is a great idea and
you're very funny doing it
they really have you playing kind of an
ass yeah i play like just a completely
demented version of myself right you're
james van der beek but you're incredibly
insane yeah yeah and i mean if like the
fake me goes on fake dancing with the
stars
um i i released my own line of way too
tight jeans
you know it's funny we have we have uh
this was i guess your network abc posted
an ad yes
it was actually they posted they put
this up on the air with no explanation
yeah no they they said you know why
don't we do it because they're called
beak jeans
yeah yeah put your cheeks in a beak yeah
yeah
um
and uh and so they said you know it
might be funny as a promotional thing if
we if we do a fake commercial so we i
looked at some you know old ridiculous
commercials and we parried it right well
then they put it online without any
mention of the show whatsoever
so people just think
james van der beek is hawking this line
of jeans
the description was on youtube celebrity
actor james van der beek releases his
own line of jeans and that was it that
was it so i can only imagine let's look
at the ad and then i just wanted to use
this let's see what people saw
who says tight jeans are just for women
everybody
not anymore
who doesn't love bj's
[Music]
i love my bj's
you will too
[Music]
big jeans
put your cheeks in a beak
[Applause]
it's
it's really funny but i can imagine that
coming up people not knowing it's a joke
yeah and then the comments
on the internet must have been insane
the comment section was pretty lively
uh-huh yeah well you look good in the
jeans well thank you
i couldn't pull that off
i've got i've got no ass it's a straight
drop not not not according to my co-star
oh kristen ritter
kristen ritter mentioned kristen ritter
i've i'm insanely in love with kristin
ritter yeah i could see why she um
i told her i was coming on your show and
literally the first words out of her
mouth she goes oh it's great conan's so
nice he's got a great butt really high
and tight that's what she said
word for word
i don't know how to take that at all
high intensity say anything about my
butt
i'm i'm still a little puzzled as to why
she thought that would be useful
information for me
james way to feel his ass
i'm glad that that's out there uh now do
you
uh you you're married is your wife okay
with you you're playing yourself you're
not playing a character you're playing a
version of yourself yeah but you act
like an incredible fool is she okay with
that or she gets self-conscious she
laughs at it but when i when i tell her
what the episode is going to be like
when i say you know this is a great
episode i volunteer at a soup kitchen so
i get my picture taken and then as soon
as the photographers leave you know i
leave right and she goes
oh boy yeah like you portray yourself as
someone who's yeah just in it for the
publicity and then you're gone
yeah drill
[Music]
there's that mean laugh again
what's that
fire alarm fire alarm so let me get this
straight james van der beek
you wait 14 years
14 years until it's safe to come back on
this show and there's a
fire
[Applause]
all right let me uh
let's sort a commercial and figure out
what we're gonna do
because the fire department loves when i
get to the plug before we evacuate
people
backwards opens in select cities next
friday don't trust the bean apartment 23
returns october 23rd on abc james van
der beek i'll see you
i got to do the math now what is it
2055. james van der beek